[Musique]
on les a massacrés ont été empoisonnés
avec l'eau
[Musique]
non
tous ces clans en fait c'était d'aider
des nomades et il suivait en fait les
lignes totémique leurs ancêtres qui
étaient des êtres spirituels à moitié
humain moi qui animaux un peu chimérique
et qui leur ont dicté leur loi
[Musique]
leur terre d'origine leur terre de
naissance est hyper important pour eux
donc les déplacés et les détacher de
leur terre c'est couper complètement le
lien qu'ils ont avec leur environnement
et leur spiritualité et leur vie sociale
en fait c'est les couper de tout donc en
à peine deux cents quarante ans la
colonisation réussi à détruire un peuple
tout entier
on a en australie on ne dit pas la
vérité dans les livres d'histoire aux
enfants enfin très peu d'australiens
savent la vérité sur leur histoire de la
colonisation ou la nie complètement il
ya des mouvements de négationnisme
hallucinant
[Musique]
ils ont des problématiques très
importante ils sont vives dans
franchement dans les communautés c'est
le tiers-monde 1 là bas donc avec une
pression pas possible de dépôt des
politiques
un racisme hallucinant donc pour s'en
sortir c'est très compliqué en étant
aborigènes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout est contre eux donc c'est difficile
de se sortir d'un cycle des chèques et
de dépression
quand rien n'est fait pour pour
justement être dans la résilience tout
est fait pour justement de de victimiser
montrer que tu n'es pas tu n'es pas
rentable tu fais rien quand tu es assis
par terre regarder l'horizon le
gouvernement trouve que
leurs pratiques sont dangereuses donc le
gouvernement leur interdit de perpétuer
leurs cérémonies et les emprisonnent
pour un oui pour un non personne n'a le
droit de venir dire à ces peuples ce
qu'ils ont à faire et comment ils
doivent le pratiquer bon je trouve qu'au
21ème siècle c'est sain c'est scandaleux
quoi